alors que tnk
c'est quoi
vous devez les allongée et parler de
votre enfance et ben voilà bah écoute
ouais là sur la scène ça va faire
leopard et on s'attend à ce que des
tabourets sont relatés un rafale alors
en jupe et les petits bonds allait
parler autant d'enfants s'il est apte à
l'est
en fait je suis un cas d'école mes
parents mes parents et ça fait beaucoup
il était il était vachement gentil avec
moi et il me laissait faire exactement
ce que je voulais mais en même temps ils
m'ont appris des notions essentielles
comme le bien le mal l'honnêteté
l'obéissance la tolérance le respect
choses comme ça donc c'est assez gavant
parlez moi de votre réveil et la
sexualité
mon éveil à la sexualité a dû faire un
âge relativement normal j'ai eu vers 13
ans quoi 12 13 ans comment ça s'est
passé comment ça s'est passé je pense
que c'est passé comme beaucoup de gens
par l'espèce de rêveries romantiques
autour de personnages de romans moi je
suis tombé dans les malheurs de sophie
les trucs comme ça c'est de la rigueur
parce que c'est l'état de jouer
ouais il souhaitait et tous tmh bande de
gaza n'aurait pas épuisé
ouais et les poissons qu'on découpe les
boissons où il ya des supers cruel
semblant et tout cela j'adorais ça donc
je pense que ça j'ai sanglant à l'époque
voilà ça commençait bien pas moi la
ville et ventriloque
est ce que tu veux qu'on passe à une
cata à guillaume à bio et docteur oui
merci julien bravo
dommage mais voilà j'ai pu le faire
c'est la lutte finale
robot louer demain la terre de la salade
aux hawks la lucha finale
'nos groupe amos kimunya là
bon luz yonn dé ka pata pata haye a dû
laisser filer